India's national flag unfurls at
Independence Day celebrations in Delhi a
symbol not only of 72 years of freedom
from British rule but now also perhaps
of the country's nationalistic shift
months after his landslide election win
Prime Minister Narendra Modi defended
his recent decision to strip Kashmir of
its special status
he said the step would restore the
disputed region's past glory it can
greatly contribute to India's
development journey we should all make
an effort to restore their old glorious
days the new arrangement is a result of
these efforts and it will work directly
in the interest of citizens as Modi
spoke indian-controlled Kashmir spent
its 11th day under a lockdown and
communications blackout authorities
there have cut internet and phone links
detained more than 500 leaders and
activists and restricted movement with
police roadblocks meanwhile in Pakistan
black flags flew at half-mast the
country observing what it called a black
day to protest Modi's decision on
Kashmir and express solidarity with
residents there tensions between India
and Pakistan hanging like a dark cloud
over the region let's get more on the
story with Nisha Jaiswal our
correspondent in Delhi hi name is char
good to see you so Modi gave a speech
today to mark Independence Day he said
that he wants to restore cashmeres past
glory what did he mean by that Modi has
once again reiterated that the last 70
years of this special state as being in
place has actually been detrimental to
Kashmir in a speech he made a few days
ago as well he talked about how its
responsibility for Indians to make sure
that Kashmiri can now participate in
India's development trajectory and this
is the point he reiterated today as well
his speeches he said that India Indians
should feel proud that we are finally
one nation one Constitution referring to
the fact that the Indian Constitution
did not apply to Kashmir in its entirety
because of the special status so this
former glory he refers to is a
reiteration of this point he's making
and which his entire government has been
making that the people of Kashmir should
finally have access to the opportunity
is the development the growth tragic
trail to the rest of India does but of
course this in the midst of an
unprecedented near complete
communications blackout in the valley
itself it tell us more about that
blackout what's been happening during
this time in Kashmir but so we the the
state of Jammu and Kashmir has been
divided into two parts and in some parts
that communications blackout has been
lifted but in the most restive part of
the state the valley of Kashmir the
communication blackout persists it's now
in its 11th day that the people of
Kashmir not only have no internet access
they also have no phone connectivity and
they actually have to line up for hours
to make a call for a few minutes to the
loved ones outside of the state the
state's justification the government's
justification for this communication
blackout is to ensure that peace is
maintained there's also been a massive
military deployment on the ground more
than what is usually out there to make
sure that there is no protests some
process however half-broken are people
here in varies from media reports there
is of course the government pushing back
saying many of these reports are not
true
but the valley continues to be in
shutdown and we are still waiting to
hear completely freely what the
residents of Kashmir you really think
about this abrogation Nimisha just very
briefly if you can Pakistan is furious
as of now appealing to the United
Nations Security Council to address
India's actions can international
mediation help defuse tensions between
Pakistan and India well sue me I'm
afraid the short answer is no the UN and
the US have been asking both countries
to to exercise restraint but also do
this through dialogue the Pakistan
Pakistan's foreign minister himself a
couple days ago said don't expect the
international community to get to
intervene but of course Pakistan
continues trying to it
nationalize the issue and hope that
there will be intervention however
because of economic interests in India's
1 billion strong population this seems
very unlikely all right our
correspondent name is Ajay while
reporting there in Delhi thank you very
much